inflation is impacting independence day  with the cost of your fourth of july  barbecue being much higher this holiday  the american farm bureau federation  reports inflated costs for just about  everything on the table the price of  ground brief has gone up 36 percent in  the last year chicken breasts and pork  chops up significantly more than 30  percent also the sides are weighing down  the wallet if you look here pork and  beans 33 percent price here lemonade 22  percent potato salad 19 percent burger  buns up 16 percent even dessert is more  costly now these cookout staples cost  the average american 59 bucks and 50  cents last year this independence day  nearly 70 dollars that is the largest  single year jump in the cost of a  cookout since the farm bureau started  tracking that data a decade ago